do you think that we're gonna find out
that the name black widow is like
is like getting belts in karate like you
start out as a white widow
and then you're a white widow with a
yellow tip and then you're a yellow
widow
nina what are the biggest questions we
want answered in black widow
well so we've gotten so many like tiny
tantalizing looks at her past right
through flashbacks and other movies i
think it was age of ultron where we kind
of got the most
look at it where the scarlet witch or
rather wanda
at the time you know brought out
everybody's worst memories
but i'm really i'm really curious to see
you know
we're gonna get her entire back story
for the first time as you said in the
entire mcu
and i'm also really excited and have a
lot of questions about the character of
elena her sister
uh played by florence pugh because i
think she's a phenomenal actress and a
great addition to the mcu so i'm just
i'm really curious to learn more about
nat and also like her family dynamics
her dynamic with elena i think it's
going to be really exciting
yeah so you want to learn all about the
family backstory for this character
you've known for over 10 years now yeah
because i mean and
you've got scarlett johansson playing
her it seems like it's been a little bit
of a waste to have such a talented you
know
someone who was nominated for two
academy awards in a year recently
to not be able to play like the more
emotional side of with natasha so
i think it's going to be it has the
potential to be a more
kind of family and relationship-centric
marvel movie
yeah cool i agree i think that that's a
really good point that
you know all we've known about her is
that she was raised in this red room and
there's some great program but
and we know that the the plot is going
to surround this program but
we don't know much else about her as a
human being
so i think that yeah i think that's a
really good
good bunch of questions to answer yeah
tom what do you think what are the
questions you want answered in black
widow
i'm also thrilled to see it uh i'm
excited to get a lot of questions
answered um
i want to find out uh what a kessel run
is
and how black widow managed to make it
in less than 12 parsecs i mean
it was hard to do but she managed it
somehow so i think that you're right
i mean in addition it would probably be
helpful if they explain
how she came up with the name black
widow i mean
right you don't just come up with a name
like that you don't just have no you're
like
you're going through customs and you're
like i'm a widow and they're like oh
what color
and right that she looks at the jacket
that she's wearing
right well it also seems like a nickname
that someone would give to you
like the kind of the kill bill like
assassin nicknames like
black mamba and rattlesnake like each
one
you know like a dangerous snake i'm like
black widow doesn't sound like something
you make up for yourself
that would be kind of lame legitimate i
mean and that's exactly the sort of
thing i'm curious about
uh did black widow's friend professor
xavier lose his hair naturally or was it
during a fight with apocalypse
uh is black widow related to ernst
stavro
um does it turn out that they were
brothers all along i'm really worried
about this movie
um i'm excited for it um
i think that scarlett johansson has made
the character so much more interesting
than i ever thought that she was in the
comics uh right
she's added a lot of depth to and so and
so joss whedon said all the
the writers but i'm very concerned about
the idea of
the president of we need to fill in
every blank
in these stories that's a good point i i
i can't think of a time when that's made
a story
more satisfying uh at least not in
recent history
i thought you're gonna say three i was
so excited you're so excited
well no you you raised a really good
point there too because this is
probably aside from captain marvel
this is well no i'm gonna i'm already
contradicting myself there have been a
few prequels right a few
jumps in time the first event captain
america the first avenger obviously took
place before
iron man one two thor
and incredible hulk so captain america
went back in time but that was for a
brand new character so it's filling in
tons of blanks but still telling a new
story
right marvel yeah go ahead oh
and just very specifically with
blackwell i think that a lot of what
makes her work is that you don't know
stuff about her you know i think that a
lot of the intrigue comes from
the mystery we we kind of get to imagine
for ourselves what you know what
happened in
budapest yes isn't that the patton
oswalt joke where he's like i don't want
to know
the backstory of my favorite characters
i just want to like them
yeah i've i've watched a couple of
videos recently about cruella i haven't
watched well yet because i don't nor
have i
care about how the villain from 101
dalmatians
became a mean lady and apparently
uh i'm not going to give away spoilers
in case anyone wants to watch it but
apparently the origin
for her distaste for uh for dalmatians
is
pretty amazing i've seen a clip of it
and it looks
insane it's one of those things where
you don't need to know you don't need to
know and so i agree that there's
definitely a danger here with black
widow in terms of
i do want i want to see the family
dynamic i want to know more about her
and her family and how she fits into
that
um i did a little research it looks like
and maybe this is
common knowledge maybe it's not
obviously we've been preoccupied over
the last year
um so i haven't dived deep into what
this movie is going to have but
apparently all the family members are
not
her biological family these are relative
family members and so it still will be
interesting to learn more and i know
that there's going to be some flashback
scenes
and i think tom raises some good good
points that if we get too
into the weeds about the details of
every every in and out of this
character's history it's going to be
a little bit it's gonna it's gonna fill
in too many blanks right like um
when uh they finally published wolverine
origin
back in the i wanna say late 90s
terrific point
yeah that's a that's a bad comic book
sorry it's not good i don't care about
seeing wolverine as a little kid
i don't care in that same vein sorry to
disappoint i think solo is a bad movie
for the same reason
like you know i'm not i don't need to
know why his name is han solo is my
point i think the movie is like fine but
i didn't need to know where his name
came from
exactly something that ever kept me up
at night so i hope
you know i hope black widow doesn't go
in one of those directions i think
there's ways that it can be a good
prequel and actually flesh out this
really interesting character but the
timing is also weird
because she's already dead exactly in
the mcu and that's
so jarring i know that there was a huge
delay obviously because of the pandemic
but
but even like delays still it still
would have come out afterwards exactly
so it's so weird to be like well this
character's back but she's not going to
be in
any future set installments that's right
very jarring do you think that we're
going to find out that the name black
widow
is like it's like getting belts in
karate like you start out as a white
widow
and then you're a white widow with a
yellow tip and then you're a yellow
widow
that would be awesome i'm actually
really down
watch out she's a brown widow was pretty
good
he's almost achieved the level of black
widow how great would it be
if it turned out that this whole movie
just takes place in like a strip mall
in russia where somebody's teaching
little girls taekwondo
it says russia but it looks exactly like
new jersey
you're like i think that's just cherry
hill i've been there
yeah a domino's guy just drove by
what's going on yeah there's a heart
there's a guitar center right in the
background why didn't they even just get
rid of that in post
you know it's just going to say guitar
ski center speed
so my one of the things that i want to
see answered tom brought it up i do want
to know what happened in budapest
it's one of those things those parts of
her character just to remind everyone
we first hear about budapest in the
first avengers movie i think they bring
it up once or twice in a couple of the
other avengers movies
um where she and hawkeye talk about it a
lot right right
black widow says this reminds me of
budapest
hawkeye says you and i have very
different recollections of budapest
i feel like you know we're probably not
going to get a flashback to budapest but
i think it would be
i think it would be a nice little fill
in the blank there to kind of give us a
sense for
this thing that they've talked about
it's it's iconic enough that we all are
talking about it even though we have no
idea what happens
and i don't feel like that would it's
not in the same
realm of oh she's um you know
this is how black widow got her jacket
this is how black widow got her
her weapons on her arm this is how black
widow got her
hair cut like right here but i do think
that that's a nice piece of
backstory that i would love to kind of
get filled in personally that's one of
the questions i'd like to see answered
personally i hope we get a haircut
montage
like like the snl black widow trailer
yeah
they did when they did a makeover yeah
there you go
that's perfect what if it's just a
romantic comedy what if it's just like
it feels exactly like 27 dresses but
it's a marvel movie
i would love a marvel romantic comedy
cat suits on people there's a voiceover
where it's like
black widow's too busy saving the world
to find love yeah and we're
we're going to talk about this
eventually about this is a different
topic but that's literally one of the
things i want them to do with she-hulk
where
she's she's a lawyer she's a she-hulk
where's she gonna find love right can a
woman have it all
when you're busy saving the world and
trying to establish a successful life
question as old as time itself yeah i
don't know yeah
i want i want i basically want liz lemon
as
she-hulk yeah and instead of running a
variety show
she's doing a superhero themed law
practice
i love it in a lot of ways the giant sky
portal above new york is like another
character in the show
which is really great
yes exactly perfect yes so yeah those
are those are all the things i
definitely think
i i think we're all we all agree here
that as far as
questions are concerned we want answers
to questions we want to know more about
this character but we don't want to know
everything and i think
one of the things that i can say with
confidence is that with black widow
it's a marvel studios movie we don't
have to worry that they're going to
shoehorn in an origin story for every
element of her character you know
we like to with solo right like you
brought up solo not being a great movie
and i think that
most people would probably agree there's
a lot about it that
works there's a lot about it that maybe
doesn't quite work and i don't
i think that a lot of that has to do
with the fact that the production had to
basically you know
change hands midway through right they
weren't sure what they were doing when
they first started
you know the the studio wanted this the
filmmakers wanted that then they bring
in ron howard and then they you know
right do all these right i mean that
movie had a lot of like troubled
production issues and black widow also
is like
the anticipation is so high because
we've been waiting so long you know we
were supposed to see this movie
over a year ago um and even that was
way too long exactly right yeah
i think it'll be i think it'll be pretty
cool
yeah i agree i'm excited who's
taskmaster what's happening with
taskmaster i want to know that part
yes so before we sign off
on this one let's talk about that um
one of our co-workers at looper
uh sarah who works in the scripps
department she and she was talking with
the rest of the team and i believe she
was one who brought up the idea that
potential spoiler alert she predicts
that it's going to be
rachel vice's character of course it's
going to be rachel nice yeah
do we all that we were having an
children
conversation if it's not rachel vice's
character i will walk out of my own
living room or wherever i watch this
video but who but i mean that's the
thing right like it's the same thing
with
you know who is the power broker right
right it's like if it's not sharon
carter
who else is left it has to be someone
who hasn't been shown in this
and so far we know it's not it's not
david harbor he doesn't fit in that suit
it's probably not florence pugh because
they're probably
getting her ready to be the next black
widow i've got a little
elena funko pop behind me actually
they're already marketing her as a new
there you go superhero black widow too
um and so then you've got rachel vice's
character who
is the mother figure yeah so
and what better storyline is there for
the mother figure to betray her
her children right naturally like we've
all gone through
sure we've all fought our mother in the
same way
that's a classic a classic story
it's so relatable yeah that's what i
like most about this idea is how
relatable it is
that's why i watch marvel movies is for
the relatability
so i guess that's the better question
then since we're all pretty much on
board with this being the reveal
i guess we hope that the reveal is
handled in a revealing and exciting way
yeah i hope it's not quite as clumsy as
you know some of the things that
we found lacking in winter soldiers
falcon winter soldiers kind of bigger
reveals so
right i'm hoping uh kate shortly the
director who's kind of like an indie
director
you know i haven't i just looked her up
and i'm not familiar with a ton of her
work so i'm curious to see
kind of how she she handles this story
and this
very likely reveal yeah i guess
i mean i guess i hope it's not her
because it seems like the obvious choice
but i don't know who else it could be i
guess it's gonna be
maybe it'll be it'll be some other
character that we're introduced to
that we are not even aware of and maybe
super big awesome secret surprise that
would be great i would love that
yeah i think it was really brave that
they decided to go with an indie
director
especially after crystal skull sucks so
[Laughter]
bad
[Laughter]
you did it you did it tom just we gotta
we gotta freeze frame him like like
breakfast club style
thanks for joining us please hit like
and subscribe so you don't miss a single
new episode